DEMOOME TO THE
DEMOMBLY GOVERNMENT
DEMONIZATION COMMITTEE HERE
DEMOE GOING TO GO AHEAD BEGAN
AS A SUB DEMOITTEE AS WE AWAIT
THE DEMOBLISHMENT OF A QUORUM.
THE DEMOT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF THE DEMOF THAT HAVE.
DEMO A TURN MADE HARBOR TO THE
DEMOTAL TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE.
DUE TO THE CAN CAN DEMO HOME
DEMOE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DEMOANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
DEMO AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
DEMODING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO DEMO A LIMITED NUMBER OF
DEMOLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE DEMOING IN PERSON. SO
DEMOIRE IN THE MASS WAR HAS
DEMOANCE BE MADE. BY MEMBER OF
THE DEMOIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
DEMO IN THE ROOM. OR THE VIDEO
DEMOERENCING SITES. IF YOU'RE
NOT DEMO A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR DEMO WE HAVE A FEW
DEMOERENT OPTIONS FOR THIS
DEMOIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE DEMO TODAY IN THE
DEMOMBLY CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY
DEMOMMODATE A MINIMAL
DEMOINGENT OF STAFF OF A
DEMOTED NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN
DEMOA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN. SIX
DEMO OF SPACE AND- THEY'RE ALSO
DEMOCT PHYSICAL DISTANCING PRO
TO. THE DEMOIC TO ENTER OR
DEMOE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
WHO DEMOE. IF I MEMBER OF THE
DEMOIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO DEMOIFY IN A BILL. RAISE
DEMO HAND. AND I'LL ASK YOU A
TO MY- A THE DEMOOACH TIME. I
DEMOD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE DEMOA. YOU CAN EXIT THE
DEMOING ROOM WHICH YOU'RE DONE
TO DEMORN YOUR SEATS. THESE
DEMO TO OBSERVERS DISTANCE UPON
DEMOING THE CAPITAL. LIMITING
L. YOU TO ONE DEMOON AT A- IN
DEMOTION TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
DEMO INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE
DEMO SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING
USE OF ONE OF OUR DEMOESS VIDEO
DEMOERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
DEMOTED HERE IN APPLE REMOTE.
DEMOIMONY ON THE CAPITAL
DEMONDS AND IN LOW. THROUGHOUT
DEMOE. THE WITNESSES WILL BE
DEMOST SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
DEMOR TEN. LIVE FROM OUTSIDE
THE DEMOING ROOM AND ALSO- ASK.
FOR DEMO IN WITNESSES WE WILL.
DEMO BE USING A MODERATE TELE
DEMOICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
DEMOESS CONTEST ON A BILL. THE
DEMO IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS DEMOT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO DEMOT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
DEMOAT THAT ONE TIME IS. EIGHT
DEMON SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
DEMO SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO DEMO TWO SIX TWO. SEVEN
DEMOAT THAT ONE MORE TIME THE
DEMOSS CODE IS. FOUR TWO SIX
TWO DEMOE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
DEMO THIS NUMBER IN THE
DEMOMBLY GEO COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS DEMO AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
IF DEMORE CALLING IN PLEASE
DEMO TO DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE DEMO. YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
DEMONNING AT THEIR BILL
DEMOENTATION SO WE CAN GET YOU
IN THE DEMOE. THE OPERATOR
DEMONE GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE DEMOED IN THE QUEUE
DEMOD ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
DEMOSE THE BILL. IF YOU'RE
DEMOING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
DEMOGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
DEMONG YOUR LIVESTREAM
DEMODCAST ON YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO DEMOCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
DEMOSE ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOU
DEMO A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
DEMOIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
DEMO YOUR REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE
IT DEMO NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF
DEMOL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK.
IF DEMORE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
DEMO RED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
DEMO THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
DEMO THREE ONE NINE. TWO FIVE
DEMOE ONE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
DEMOE TO ASSIST YOU. ALSO ONE
DEMO THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
DEMOTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
DEMOTION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
DEMOITTEE'S WEBSITE SO THAT'S
AN DEMOON AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR DEMOING WITH US AS WE
DEMOEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO DEMOE THE PEOPLE OF
DEMOFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
DEMOFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
DEMOIC HEALTH CONCERNS YOU'RE
DEMOCE. WITH THAT. WE'RE GONNA
GO DEMOD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM
DEMOETARY CALL THE ROLL GREAT
DEMO BIGELOW. AGUILAR BERMAN.
DEMOA COOLEY COOPER DALY
DEMOAGHER. AND WATER GARCIA.
DEMOON JONES SAWYER LACKEY LOW
DEMOIS. WORKS ROBERT RIVAS.
DEMOKING AND SALAS. WE HAVE A
DEMOUM. OKAY THANK YOU MEMBERS.
DEMOERS WE ONE A GENT ITEM
DEMOH IS CONSENT CALENDAR I'VE
DEMO INFORMED THAT ITEM NUMBER
DEMO- SB SEVEN NINE FOUR
DEMOSON- IS BEING PULLED FROM
THE DEMOENT CALENDAR THEY WILL
DEMO TO. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE DEMO A SECOND. GREAT NOT
DEMONG BIGELOW. AGUIAR-CURRY
DEMOAN. BERMAN I BONTA. COOLEY
DEMOEY AYE COOPER COOPER AYE
DEMO. YES THIS IS. GALLAGHER
DEMORDO GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON
HI DEMOS JONES SAWYER I'D
DEMOEY LACKEY AYE LOW. MATT
DEMO. MATHIS AYE QUIRK SILVA.
DEMOK SILVA HI ROBERT RIVAS.
DEMOCA RUBIO WHAT THE RUBIO AYE
DEMOS. BECAUSE THAT COUNTERS
DEMO ADOPTED. BONTA BONTA HI.
THE DEMOLOW Y. OKAY SEC
DEMONDARS BEEN ADOPTED THE
DEMOERS CAN ADD ON. AT THIS
DEMO- MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
DEMO TO THE REMAINING ITEM ON
THE DEMODA WHICH IS ITEM FOUR-
DEMO IS SB SEVEN NINE FOUR-
DEMOSON EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
DEMOCOMMUNICATIONS IS THE
DEMOTOR HERE. YET I WOULD
DEMOFY THE CENTERS OFFICE THIS
DEMORT FOR YOU CAN WE CAN HAVE
A DEMOT NOTIFY THE CENTERS ON
DEMOS DO THAT. MEMBERS WILL
DEMO A- FIVE MINUTE RECESS TO
DEMOFY THE CENTERS OFFICE- FOR
DEMO THE OPPORTUNITY TO SENSE
DEMO UP AND THE BILL IF NOT ALL
DEMOENT THE BILL ABSENCE OF SO.
DEMOEVER THEIR.
DEMO. I.
DEMO
DEMO RIGHT ALL.
THE DEMO. SO.
SO.
DEMO. ROLL.
DEMO.
DEMOCT.
DEMO YEAH. RIGHT YEAH MY
DEMO. YEAH. THAT. THERE ARE.
DEMO WE'RE GONNA BRAIN DECEMBER
GEO DEMOITTEE TO ORDER- MEMBERS
WE HAD A DEMOSS PLEASE RETURN
TO DEMOITTEES WE CAN FINISH OUR
DEMONESS WE'RE GOING TO- MOVED
DEMO FOR ON THE GENERAL LAST
DEMOINING ITEM SB SEVEN NINE
DEMO JACKSON- MERCHANT SERVICES
DEMOCOMMUNICATION I'M GOING TO
DEMO THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE
DEMORMAN SERVER. AND I'M GO
DEMOD PERCENT THE BILL ON
DEMOLF OF THE SO. MISTER
DEMORMAN SB SEVEN NINE FOUR YOU
DEMO THE FLOOR FOR MISS
DEMOSON'S BILL. THANK YOU
DEMOER VICE CHAIR. MEMBERS. SB
DEMON NINE FOUR JACKSON RELATED
DEMOICES AND TELL COMMITTEE.
SIX DEMO A MERCHANT OF PROGRAM
DEMO CAL TO INCLUDE CITIES AND
DEMOERSAL BY CLAIRE THAT TO
DEMONING MAY USE WHY TELEPHONE
DEMOCRIBE DATA TO A WORLD AND
DEMOL ALERTING SO AND
DEMOORIZED COUNTY SOCIAL
DEMORTMENTS TO CON INFO. OF
DEMOORS DISABLED AND VERY WITH
A DEMO OF TO MANAGER EVACUATION
DEMOIFIC MEMBERS BILL XP THE
DEMO TO SEE ESTABLISH AGREEMENT
DEMO PUBLIC FROM OR- CITIES
DEMO RESIDENT REPUBLICAN
DEMOINGS TO NOTIFY RISE MOMENT
DEMOORIZES GOVERNMENTS TO USE
IT DEMO SEARCH FIRMS OBTAIN THE
DEMORACTOR FOR AT REQUIRE LOW
DEMORNMENTS THE CON FOR FROM
DEMOR OWN SERVICE. TO RESIDENTS
DEMO. MOREOVER ARISES THE GUY
DEMO POST TO ARE RECEIVED FUNDS
DEMO ITS OWNER. IT REQUIRES
DEMOE GOVERNED BY TO OUR A
DEMOIC OF WAR SYSTEM TO BILL.
IF ANY DEMOOYEE OF A SOCIAL CAN
DEMOICE TO PART TO JUST TELL
DEMOER EMAIL. WRITER FORMS AND
DEMO FORM HAS SPECIFIC
DEMOBILITIES OF DRAWBACKS
DEMOEMS RANGING RELATIVELY LOW
DEMO OPTIONS LIKE MAKING DOOR
TO DEMOUNCEMENTS OF FORT TO
DEMOOOR WARNING SIRENS TO AUTO
DEMONG TELEPHONES THAT TO A
DEMOILED. OF TO HOUSES AND A
DEMOK BY BLOCK LEVEL. MANY
DEMOSDICTION AND RELY THE OLD
LOW UP DEMOS NUMBERS YOU KNOW.
DEMOEMS AND ORDER CAN YOU WITH.
DEMO CAN SIMPLY RECORD MESSAGES
LOK DEMOIN HARD AREAS WELL AS
TAX OF O DEMO TOWER. GIVEN THE
DEMOITY TO TARGET USING ADDRESS.
DEMOL OPERATED NO SYSTEMS
DEMOND THEM PRECISE ARMOR OUT
OF SO TO IN DEMOS TODAY. BUT
DEMOUSE OF A- MOBILE FOR WAS
NOT DEMOL WE- AND I PROCESS.
DEMOERS I WOULD ASKED FOR YOUR
DEMOORT OF. THIS BILL AFTERNOON
DEMO A LOT FROM A SO COOL. AND
WE DEMO A SECOND FROM
DEMOMBLYMEMBER JOHNSON. MISTER
DEMOR. ALL THE FOR YOU IF YOU
DEMO CHAIR GET THAT MYSELF TO
IN THE DEMOIER. THE MOST AND
THE IN A DEMOERLY MADE RECORD
DEMOS OPEN THE FLOOR TO DISK
FOR DEMOLE FROM THE. WE GO TO
THE DEMOE. IS THERE ANYONE
DEMOING TO A THE ON SOME BILL
DEMOLY SENATE BILL SEVEN FOUR
DEMO JACKSON'S BILL A BRITISH
BY DEMO WE DO HAVE SEVERAL.
DEMOS SUPPORT HERE TO WITH
DEMOE CALIFORNIA CITIES AS AT
THE DEMOERSITY HEALTH DO WE
DEMOER CHOI HARVEY. I BELIEVE
DEMOERS CONFERENCE IT'S.
DEMOTEEN ANTI OPERATOR CAN YOU
DEMO IS AT THIS TIME AND OPEN
THE DEMOE LINES TO THE PUBLIC
DEMO WISH TO ADDRESS US. HELLO
DEMOTY ANTI OPERATOR.
DEMOE
DEMOING ON IT PUBLIC. IT'S JUST
DEMO OF THE TECHNICAL.
DEMOLENGE THAT WE FACE EVERY
DAY DEMO THANK YOU MISTER
DEMOHER.
DEMOE WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE AT AND T. WE DEMO TO
SEE IF DEMOERS WOULD LIKE TO
DEMO ANY QUESTIONS. AND OPEN
THE DEMOR UP TO MEMBERS ARE
DEMOE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
DEMOERS ON SENATE BILL SEVEN
DEMOTY FOUR MS JACKSON'S BILL.
I SEE NO ONE DEMONG TO THAT
DEMO IT THIS TIME. WE ARE SHORT
OF FEW DEMOERS IF WE COULD ASK
DEMOE MEMBERS OR THEIR STAFF TO
DEMOK WITH THEIR MEMBER TO SEE
IF. DEMO CAN COME BACK TO THE
DEMOR WE WOULD APPRECIATE IT AS
WE DEMO PROBABLY BE VOTING ON
DEMO. SOON EIGHTEEN TEAR YOU.
OUT DEMOE. AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DEMOECT RECONNECT THE LINK.
DEMO YOU GOT THE LINK. HELLO
DEMOTY ANTI. I CAN HEAR YOU
DEMOK YOU WERE ON SENATE BILL
DEMON NINETY FOUR JACKSON DO
YOU DEMO- POKES WISHING TO
DEMOESSES ON THIS BILL. I CAN
DEMOAINLY ASK ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YES DEMOES GENTLEMEN. LADIES
AND DEMOLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
DEMO A FEW PEOPLE HERE GIVE ME
ONE DEMONT PLEASE THEY'RE
DEMOENTLY WITH OPERATORS. THANK
YOU FOR DEMO PATIENCE VERTICAL
DEMO NUMBER SEVENTEEN ONE
DEMONTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
DEMO YES MY NAME JOY THAT THE-
I'M DEMO. A R. P. AND IT
DEMORDS THREE MILLION MEN AND
CAL AND WE. SB DEMON NINETY.
DEMOK YOU WE'RE ON SENATE BILL
DEMON NINE FOUR JACK YOU HAVE
BOB DEMO WISHING TO ADDRESS ON
DEMO CAN YOU ME FIVE CERTAINLY
ASK DEMON. YES THE ONLY. YEAH.
ONE DEMO AT THE TIME. OKAY
DEMOAR TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF.
DEMOO MY NUMBER. ONE EACH MY
DEMO IS JOYCE BALL. P. AND- YOU
DEMO THE NUMBER CALIFORNIA AND
THE DEMOT BUT SEVEN NINE COULD
DEMO UP THANK YOU WE'RE A LOT
DEMOTE BILL. OKAY WELL NEXT
DEMOS LINE NUMBER FOUR LINE
DEMO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE FROM
THE DEMOERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
DEMOKING IN SUPPORT OF SB.
DEMON NINETY FOUR. ENACT SOME
OF DEMOT NEXT MOVES TO ONE
DEMOER FORTY THREE ONE FORTY
DEMOE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
DEMOARY CARRYING ON BEHALF OF
DEMO THEM IN SUPPORT. LINE
DEMOY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HER DEMOD DISABILITY RIGHTS
DEMOFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE
DEMOTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
DEMO. PHONE CRIME BY THE HOLY-
DEMO YOUR TOWN COUNTRY FOUND
DEMOG THEM YEAH AND THE OF. IT
BE DEMO. ONE SEVEN FIVE. YES
DEMOE WORKING SENATE BILL SEVEN
DEMO FOUR. AN EXCELLENT TO LINE
DEMOER TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW DEMO. MY NAME IS ALSO FROM
DEMO CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
DEMOORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
DEMON IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
DEMOSE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
DEMO. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE DEMO SHOWING SUPPORT TO
DEMOSE CONTINUE. CAN YOU CHECK
AND SEE IF DEMOLES HARVEY WITH
THE DEMOUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IS ON THE DEMOE I BELIEVE. IT
DEMOESTED THAT HE MIGHT BE
DEMOING IN. IF YOU'RE NOT ONE
DEMOSE PRESS ONE AND ZERO WE
CAN DEMOST YOU BY OPENING YOUR
DEMO. MSRP IF YOU'RE ON THE
DEMO CAN YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO WE CAN OPEN UP YOUR LINE.
I DEMOT HAVE AN ACUTE UP. OKAY
DEMO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
DEMOSITION IS THERE ANY
DEMOSITION. HELLO MANISHA
DEMOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
DEMO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN A
DEMO OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE DEMO AT THIS TIME. AND I
DEMO NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
DEMOSE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
DEMO- WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
DEMOERY- I DON'T SEE ANY FOLKS
DEMOING TO THE CALL THEIR
DEMOKA SECOND TIME FOR MEMBERS
ARE DEMOE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
DEMOERS ON SB SEVEN NINE FOUR.
DEMONG NO ONE FROM THAT. I'LL
DEMO BRING IT BACK TO FOR VOTE.
DEMOD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
DEMOR THANK YOU- THIS
DEMOAURANT. APPRECIATE THE
DEMORTUNITY PRESENT THE BILL
AND ON DEMOLF OF THE SENATE
DEMO REQUEST SPECIFICALLY
DEMOEST JOURNAL. PLEASE CALL
THE DEMO SB SEVEN NINE FOUR
DEMOSON THE MOTION IS DUE
DEMOED TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY.
DEMOLOW AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
DEMOA. COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DEMO GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA
DEMOON JONES SAWYER JONES
DEMOER AYE LACKEY LACKEY I LOW
DEMOIS QUIRK SILVA.
DEMORT RIVAS BLANCA RUBIO. AND
DEMOS. THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES.
WE DEMO A NUMBER OF VOTES
DEMOINING- WILL PUT THAT A BILL
ON DEMO AND ALLOW FIVE MINUTES
DEMO TIME- FOR MEMBERS TO COME
DEMO- TO THE STAFF OF THOSE
DEMOERS ARE ON THE GEO
DEMOITTEE COULD YOU PLEASE TALK
TO DEMO MEMBERS ABOUT COMING
DEMO IN VOTING. THANK YOU VERY
DEMO WE HAVE FIVE MINUTES FROM
THE DEMOKS TIME AS NOW.
DEMO
DEMO YEAH. YEAH OTHER THAN THAT.
DEMOK YOU WERE COMING BACK TO
SEE DEMO THE OF FIVE MINUTES A
DEMO PERIOD- THIS BILL DOES NOT
DEMO TO ENJOY THE FULL BREADTH
OF DEMOS WE STILL HAVE A NUMBER
SO IT DEMOS AS TODAY BUT IT IS
THE DEMOOR IS AFFORDED A
DEMONSIDERATION- FOR THIS BILL
TO BE RE DEMOD. MISTER CHAIR. I
DEMOEVE THAT COVERS YOUR AGENDA
FOR YOU DEMOY. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO DEMOD IN A JOURNAL OR
DEMOD YOU LIKE ME TO ADJOURN OR
DO YOU DEMO SOME OTHER FORMAL
DEMONESS. WE HAVE A NUMBER
DEMONG BACK. WE'RE HAPPY TO
DEMO FOR THAT. HOLD ON A MISTER
DEMOS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
DEMOS I. THANK YOU.
ON THE
DEMOENT CALENDAR SALAS HI. DO
WE DEMO ANY MORE MEMBERS COMING
DEMO SO THAT CONCLUDES
DEMOYTHING AGAIN I WILL
DEMOERATE ON SB SEVEN NINETY
DEMO JACKSON'S BILL IT IS
DEMORDED WITHOUT- IT IS
DEMORDED RECONSIDERATION
DEMOOUT OBJECTION. THANK YOU
DEMO MUCH.